we're not only deeply inspired by the
beautiful people the rich music and
engaging stories of the South Pacific
but we were also deeply changed by them
I'm thrilled to bring out the filmmakers
of Moana these great filmmakers have
done some of the most classic films for
the Walt Disney Animation Studios films
like The Little Mermaid in Aladdin
ladies and gentlemen directors John
Musker and Ron Clements and the producer
of Moana Osan sure we're here with you
at d23 to announce our musical team for
the first time our team is made up of
three members the first it's named opt
FYE
opt is a musician from the South Pacific
as a band called tea vodka that has won
multiple World Music Awards and there
are huge huge superstars in the South
Pacific second on our team it's mark
Mann chena who is a composer many of you
have heard of him he's done so many
Disney films did Connor and speed and
the plains movies and of particular
relevance to our movie also The Lion
King and last but not least
lin-manuel miranda amazing songwriter
he's known for in the heights which he
wrote and starred in won a Tony and an
Emmy and for Hamilton which opened on
Broadway last week and it's awesome if
you haven't seen it go it's a hip-hop
version of the life of Alexander
Hamilton and it's fantastic
ladies and gentlemen could you please
put your hands together and give a warm
d23 Expo welcome to the voice of Maui
the man the myth the legend
what is up d23 Expo I am so excited to
be with you here today to talk a little
bit about about Maui and our incredible
story of Moana but really quickly before
I do that I just want to share something
quickly with the room I'd shared this
with John Lasseter backstages when I
first got in this business 15 years ago
I've been a lucky guy I've had a pretty
good career over the years I had a goal
and the goal was to be in the Disney
family the yes Samoa is in my blood and
to tell a story inspired by the South
Pacific
is truly a great honor
you